un ciel gris mais pas de pluie ce matin
changement de météo après dix jours de
précipitations une eau plus que
bienvenue dans ce champ de blé on voit
que les feuilles sont étalés quand vous
avez un manque d'eau la plante à
n'attendre se reproduit les les feuilles
se rétracte sebring et si la pluie tombe
en abondance ces derniers jours le
printemps lui était sec
en avril il est tombé sur l'exploitation
de jean christophe seulement 11
millimètres d'eau contre 79 au mois
d'avril 2018 alors il a même été
contraint d'irriguer ça a été très
intense et 18 heures par jour boulot
l'irrigation c'est pas un métier de
plaisir contrairement à ce que certains
croient irrigué c'est pas que ça fait
plaisir à l'agriculteur la meilleure
rossello du ciel elle est gratuite
elles tombent partout et d'autant que
son exploitation est vaste 280 hectares
outre le blé jean-christophe cultive la
betterave l'orge et le colza et la météo
a toute son importance le bon temps de
l'agriculteur c'est un temps alterner
entre de la pluie du soleil des temps
poussant alors un temps poussant c'est
un temps doux ça peut être du froid
certaine époque de l'année de la neige
aussi parce que ça protège les plantes
l'épisode pluvieux devrait durer météo
france prévoit de la pluie pour les huit
prochains jours